in beyond glory author David Marr Golic
recounts the political impact of the
heavyweight fights between
african-american Joe Lewis and German
max schmeling in 1936 and 1938 he spoke
about it recently at codys books in
berkeley california for about an hour 15
minutes welcome to codys bookstore we're
very pleased this evening to have David
Margaux Luke two boxers african-american
Joe Lewis and the German Max Schmeling
fought two heavyweight fights the first
in 1936 and the second in 1938 these
fights are reflective of the hopes
hatreds and fears of a world moving
towards war after seven years of
research on riding on a fight that only
lasted two minutes and four seconds
David Margaux liquor joins us to discuss
beyond glory joe lewis vs. Max Schmeling
and a world on the brink david has spent
the last four years as a contributing
editor at Vanity Fair magazine and prior
to that spent 15 years at the New York
Times this is his fourth book please
welcome David margalit thanks Rachel I
want to thank everybody for coming out
tonight I very much appreciate your
being here and I'm going to read from
the very beginning of the book which I
hope sets things up nicely and might
help to explain as Rachel said why it
took me seven years to write about a
fight that lasted only 124 seconds and
conveys the idea that it was really much
more than a fight on the morning of jun
22nd 1938 the New York Journal American
plastered an enormous cartoon across the
front page of its sports section
ringside tonight it was titled it
depicted a darkened stadium topped by a
circle of flags silhouette it against
the evening sky and
closing a small illuminated square
inside that square were two tiny figures
one black one white heading towards each
other with their arms raised about to
come to blows looking on was a mob of
people discernible near the action and
visible in the distance only as tiny
specks of light and sitting by the ropes
was a giant anthropomorphic globe with
oversized bug eyes and a furrowed brow
superimposed over the lines of latitude
and longitude the orb held a small sign
which read main bout Joe Lewis us versus
Max Schmeling Germany had you picked up
any other newspaper that day in Berlin
or London or Tokyo or Johannesburg or
Moscow the message would have been the
same something extraordinary was about
to happen in New York City around 10pm a
timekeeper would strike a small bell and
much of a world still unaccustomed to
acting in unison would cease whatever it
was doing and come to attention in
Yankee Stadium nearly 70,000 fans would
lean forward in their seats throughout
the rest of the world a hundred million
people or more the largest audience in
history for anything would gather around
their radios everything else would
suddenly cease to matter wars involving
the fate of Nations rage elsewhere on
this globe the New York mirror had
declared that morning but the eyes of
the world will be focused tonight on a
two-man battle in a ribbon of light
stabbing the darkness of the Yankee
Stadium the on Griff the mouthpiece of
Nazi propaganda minister Joseph Goebbels
had a little in common with the mirror a
tabloid red primarily by working class
American Jews but regarding this point
the two newspapers agreed on this day
the on Griff observed two men will hold
an entire world in the utmost tension 20
million Germans would join the 60
million Americans who would be listening
even though it would be three o'clock
the next morning and
Berlin when the gong sounded much of
Germany would simply not go to bed five
months before Cristal knocked the night
of the broken glass the pogrom that
would signal the end of any remaining
semblance of normal Jewish life in
Germany the Nazi state would experience
with one newspaper called the night of
the bright windows unique among the
sports boxing seemed to crystallize the
ethnic racial and political tensions of
a culture but even to veteran boxing
writers this fight between a 24 year old
black American and a German nine years
his senior between the World Heavyweight
Champion and a former title holder and
the only man ever to beat him in his
professional career was unlike any other
it was not just black against white
which was combustible enough but youth
versus age raw talent and instinct vs
experience freedom against fascism and
in its own way the Jews vs. out off
Hitler since the moment two years
earlier when and one of the greatest
upsets in the history of sports Max
Schmeling had knocked out the
purportedly unstoppable Joe Lewis people
had savored the idea of a rematch for
months now it had been analyzed from
every possible angle Lewis are smelling
the great sports writer Grantland rice
asked these two names beat upon your
eardrums as steadily as the tom-toms of
a Zulu tribe moving to a raid no single
sporting event even Jack Johnson's
victory over Jim Jeffries in 1910 which
sparked race riots throughout the United
States or anything in the nineteen
thirty-six olympics in berlin had ever
born such worldwide wait the fight
implicated both the future of race
relations in the prestige of two
powerful nations each fighter was
bearing on his shoulders more than any
athlete ever had in a nation still
wracked by the depression people had
spent nearly a million dollars for
tickets something that had happened in
boxing only a few times before and only
during boom times
judges and lawyers representatives and
senators governors and mayor's bankers
and brokers merchant Prince and
industrial giants doctors artists
writers figures of prominence in the
various fields of sports champions of
the past and present in the ring stars
of the stage and screen everybody it
seems will be at or near ringside that
night the New York Times predicted but
equally impressive were those in the
bleachers many of them black who had dug
down deep into their pockets in their
cookie jars sacrificed their relief
checks pawned the precious little they
owned for the privilege of watching too
distant specs new battle and to be at
least for a little while at what felt
like the center of the universe by ten
o'clock the streets in most American
cities would be utterly deserted with
open windows offering the only defense
against summertime heat and humidity the
sounds of the fight would float out of
homes and apartments spilling into the
streets and reverberating around empty
courtyards in movie theaters and
restaurants at baseball games and dances
the fight would be piped in four months
later when seabiscuit beat war admiral
perhaps 40 million Americans would be
listening tonight 60 million would be
nearly half of the country's population
more people than had ever heard one of
Franklin D Roosevelt fireside chats of
course anyone missing the action on NBC
could read plenty about it the next
morning by one estimate more journalists
would gather at Yankee Stadium than had
been adverse I for the formal end of
world war one then as now New York City
was usually two sprawling and to imprint
imperturbable to bend very much to
anything in its midst the place
swallowed up sporting events no matter
the magnitude World Series scarcely
caused a crush on the subways one sports
writer observed two days before the
fight Olympic tryouts go on unheeded
international tennis matches are just
murmurs in the city's roar but even New
York and all its millions wouldn't
submerge this fight he went on it
dominated everything
hotels restaurants and nightclubs were
jammed more blacks had flooded into New
York than at any time in its history
since all of Harlem's hostelries were
filled and since hotels downtown were
either too expensive or too
discriminatory these visitors were
sleeping in their cars whatever
prosperity black America could muster in
these worst of times was on display
either on wheels are on their backs are
in the in the hands of bookies if Joe
loses and no one here even thinks that
so many tears will flow down 7th and
Lenox avenues that it will seem like a
mississippi river flood the Amsterdam
news Harlem's principal newspaper
reported on the other hand if Joe wins
more liquor will be consumed than there
is an Old Man River as many as 2,000
Germans had come to New York for the
fight most of them aboard mighty ocean
liners like the Bremen or the Europa
swastikas flying from their masts all
were fired up by pre fight coverage in
the Nazi press which predicted that
Schmeling was simply too superior to
Louis both as a boxer and as a man to
lose Hitler had been a boon to German
boxing he had extolled it in mine comp
and insisted it be taught in German
schools what made for good fighters
courage resolve speed cold-blooded
calculation made for good soldiers too
he said in Reich sports culture The
Daily Worker had wise cracked boxing was
second only to Jew baiting in popularity
the Nazis initially had little use for
professional athletes they serve the
wrong God themselves Schmeling moreover
was dark and brooding and had an almost
Asian cast a far cry from the lithe and
cheery Aryan blondes of leni riefenstahl
films but Schmeling ability to confound
his critics to rebound from defeat to
prevail by sheer force of character and
will embodied the Nazi vision of a Renee
sentry when he had beaten Louis two
years earlier the Nazis had embraced him
smelling victory a German victory they
titled the film of that fight which was
shown throughout Germany
by Hitler's personal decree to enormous
audiences of rapturous fans the first
nationally sponsored heavyweight one
American writer called Schmeling but
placating Hitler in the American
simultaneously was a challenge even for
the nimble and malleable schmeling in
the United States boxing met New York
and New York in large part met Jews the
man who controlled the sport in New York
and who was promoting tonight's fight
was Jewish many boxers including
champions and several divisions were
Jewish so were many of the trainer's
writers and suppliers as well as an
enormous number of fans so too were most
of the fight managers including
Schmeling this irritated the Nazis but
it was they surely realize the price
they had to pay to do business in New
York 45 near five years now New York
fans had looked where only upon
Schmeling and upon his insistence that
he was a sportsman rather than a
politician and that nothing was amiss
back home many came to consider him as
much a German product as Krupp steel
someone whose purses helped propped up
prop up a brutal but financially
strapped regime and they had boycotted
his fights for a time the fights
promoter talked of moving the bow to a
venue where there were fewer Jews but he
ultimately decided that despite the
political pressures the Jews would come
out to see this fight anyway they were
too eager to see Luis Luis slaughter
Schmeling to stay away this hatred only
made Germany embrace Schmeling more
tenaciously on the morning of the fight
Hitler sent a telegram wishing him luck
that Schmeling was fighting a black man
and on behalf of a regime for which race
was paramount up the symbolic ante All
Whites the Nazis asserted were in
Schmeling scorner not just in Germany
but in the American South Australia
South America and South Africa German
commentators had repeatedly charged that
the United States was more concerned
about retaining the heavyweight crown
than about upholding the honor of the
white race so the task had fallen to
Germany that anyone could accuse a
segregated and bigoted America of giving
people of color a break was almost
common
but Louis only the second black man ever
to win the heavyweight title and the
first in 22 years had made himself
indispensable and just as remarkably
largely acceptable to white America I'm
going to see heifetz one man tells
another oh yeah the second man replies
who's he fighting it is an old gag but
it captures the power in reach of boxing
in the United States before World War
two once the fight game had been a sport
of back of back rooms and lowlifes
gamblers and thugs but in the Jazz Age
it had become legal respectable
glamorous and omnipresent it's male
working-class constituency expanded to
the wealthy to intellectuals to women
and in particular society women epic
contests attracted tens of thousands of
people and two instances more than a
hundred thousand the kingdom called
fists iana reached into nearly every
city neighborhood in town each had its
own arenas boxing clubs and favorites on
any given night in New York fans could
choose between a dozen fights and as
many venues pitting Irishmen against
Jews against Italians against poles
fisty Anna had its own scribes usually
the best writers of paper had floods and
strikes the journalist Heywood Bruin
once wrote were for second stringers the
Depression had knocked some of the oomph
at a professional boxing as had the
retirement of luminaries like Jack
Dempsey and gene Tunney the sport
sputtered as a series of less glamorous
champions Schmeling among them quickly
came and went but a heavyweight title
fight was still the most lavish
anticipated spectacle in all of sports
unlike baseball football hockey golf or
tennis it crossed all borders and
classes if boxing had brought classes
together it brought the races together
to more than in almost any other segment
of American life fight crowds at
heavyweight bouts had become integrated
at least since Joe Lewis had come along
even if most black sat in the cheap
seats in the stadium one black writer
observed
the wall between the races was far
thinner than in almost any church and if
in the ring and in the ring more than
anywhere else blacks had now come to
believe they could be judged fairly it
hadn't always been so if a black man was
too good damon runyon once wrote whites
wouldn't fight him and if it was no good
well then what good was he only a few
years before Lewis turned professional a
New York paper mistakenly called a white
fighter black and the fighter suit
fighters sued for libel but Lewis was
too good a boxer and too good for boxing
to keep down he was a precise and
devastating puncher with both hands and
his Runyon himself noted the public
loves a puncher white black yellow or
green he invariably scored knockouts
clean and quick ferocious and
unequivocal white America was vaguely
embarrassed by its love of boxing but
black America felt few qualms for blacks
boxing offer to breach in the ghetto
wall the Rope square at least with Lewis
inside it meant a square deal you can't
jim crow on left hook was how another
great box or Henry Armstrong had put it
the ring Malcolm X was to write in his
autobiography was the only place a Negro
could whip a white man and not be
lynched more had been written about
Lewis in the previous few years Runyan
speculated than about anyone besides
Charles a Lindbergh a Midwestern
professor asked his students to identify
Jarnell Lewis Joe Lewis and Sinclair
Lewis few had heard of the Labour leader
or the or the author but nearly all knew
the brown bomber Lewis's appeal was no
accident by temperament and design he
had tried to be everything the much
vilified still controversial previous
black title holder Jack Johnson was not
dignified gentle self-effacing
unthreatening while white sometimes
patronized him a big superbly built
Negro youth who was born to listen to
jazz music eat a lot of fried chicken
play ball with the gang on
the corner and never do a lick of heavy
work he could escape bill quorum of the
New York Evening Journal had written of
him the previous year they generally
liked him even below the mason-dixon
line one black column is estimated as
the lewis Schmeling fight approached
that two of three white southerners were
pulling for Lewis for Lewis then much of
the bigotry that afflicted America was
briefly and selectively suspended in
black America Lewis was idolized as as
no one had ever been writers compared
him to booker t washington the biblical
David and Jesus Christ black newspapers
were filled with poems about him
musicians composed songs about him
preachers who had once deemed
prizefighting crooked and unchristian
extolled him from the pulpit families
hung pictures of him in their parlors
even Jesse Owens the only black athletes
arrival him in fame and accomplishment
became in his exalted presence just
another rabid fan day by day since their
alleged emancipation they have watched a
picture of themselves being painted as
lazy stupid and diseased Richard Wright
wrote to black America he went on Lewis
symbolized the living refutation of the
hatred spewed forth daily over radios in
newspapers in movies and in books about
their lives Lewis that blacks everywhere
think lofty and heretical thoughts if he
could shatter racial barriers those
barriers could not be so formidable the
sports pages put Lewis's reach at 76
inches in fact it was global but for all
this black America was hedging its bets
Lewis had burned them once when he lost
his Melling in 1936 and besides the
black community never took anything
particularly anything good for granted
the Harlem that that one black visitor
encountered before the white the fight
was quiet and fearful as if everyone
were in prayer after showers earlier in
the day the weather in the Bronx had
cleared by five o'clock five thousand
people were waiting to buy general
admission
tickets for three dollars and fifty
cents apiece a red cap was first in line
a cook second as darkness began to fall
thousands began making their way to the
stadium in purring limousines grinding
cabs and up from the subway slots and
grates pausing spouting geysers of
humanity Road Bob Considine in the New
York mirror from the window of her
apartment in the Sugar Hill section of
Harlem Lewis's young bride could see the
giant stadium and watch the enormous
procession making its way there by car
and on by bus and on foot she would be
listening to the fight on the radio
shortly before ten the fighters entered
the ring the NBC broadcaster Clem
McCarthy was at the microphone when the
referee Arthur Donovan summoned the two
fighters and their seconds Donovan asked
the contestants how they felt reviewed
the dangers of low blows warned their
seconds not to step through the ropes
once the fight was on he then reminded
the combatants of their responsibility
both to the crowd and to the unseen
audience beyond all of whom were
expecting one of the greatest fights
ever now let's go he concluded and may
the best man win the old slogan of
boxing may the best man win and she's
about to start with this yankee stadium
packed to the doors McCarthy exclaimed
Joe Lewis in his corner prancing and
rubbing his feet in the rasen and Max
Schmeling stand and calmly and they're
ready with the bell just about to ring
and then the bell rang thank
[Applause]
and I'm happy to take questions into
listening to this wonderful segment I
have several questions it sounded almost
like poetry how do you define the genre
of this book and i would like to also
ask what why did you feel personal
affinity with this subject yeah why did
you decide to write this well i define
this book this is not principally a
boxing book I mean this is a book that
happens to be about a boxing match but
it's a book about it's a book about the
world in the 1930s it's it's a book
about a world when I say that the tie
the subtitle is Joel joe lewis vs. max
schmeling in a world on the brink and by
a world on the brink I'm talking about a
world on the brink of war a world that
was about to change fun to be changed
fundamentally by an absolutely
catastrophic war I mean the war broke
out the following year and a world on
the brink of a civil rights revolution
the war with the war would sort of kick
start the civil rights movement the
armed forces would be integrated and and
I consider Joe Lewis to be kind of an
unsung and forgotten hero of the civil
rights movement as somebody who
generated you know the absolutely
enormous pride that not to which I refer
in the introduction here and as the
first black man the first black athlete
and really the first black man i think
that large numbers of whites ever rooted
for I mean Joe Lewis taught a whole
generation of whites about tolerance you
know and this is this is often forgotten
so you know I'm not a I'm not an
authority on boxing I was I like boxing
when I was a kid but I don't
particularly follow it now but I always
followed this fight I always cared about
this fight I knew about it from a very
early very young age because my father
had a record
of the he had edward r murrow record and
i can hear it now record and it had the
had the the blowing up of the Hindenburg
on it and it had Lou Gehrig's farewell
address and it had FDR's fireside chats
and it had Pearl Harbor and all these
different things from nineteen thirty
three to nineteen forty-five and one at
one of the one of the segments on is
Clem McCarthy's call of the fight and I
don't know how many of you have ever
heard it but you know once you hear it
you don't forget it and Schmeling is
down the count is five five six seven
eight the men are in the ring and it's
you know it just was a kind of embossed
on my brain so that even though I came
along after this fight I mean oddly
enough this fight is kind of a part of
my childhood so I always knew that I
want I was always intrigued with it but
only as I got older did I realize that
the fight incorporates all these themes
that interest me civil rights and racial
pride and dignity World War two the
history of World War two Jewish culture
because the Jews are right in the middle
of this entire story the history of Nazi
Germany radical politics New York City
there's a whole world there's a whole
world that's contained in the story and
it just reached it just reaches out it
emanates in a million different
directions which is the reason why it
took so long to write this is I hope
it's not a book it's not one of these
books that says you know on that day the
price of milk was five cents a gallon
and you know all of these sort of
extraneous facts about the time I mean
all whatever i described about the era i
think it was relevant to the fight and
everything i described about the fight
was relevant to the era that was the
whole idea up to to use the fight as
kind of a metaphor for where the world
stood in 1938 and and what you have to
do in order to write about the first the
second fight is to write about the first
fight and I have you know the first
fight in some ways is
interesting or at least as interesting
is the second fight for reasons I'm
happy to explain and you have to trace
both of the fighters careers you have to
explain Joe Louis's appearance on the
scene and what end and which is a which
is an extraordinary story in his own
right and you have to you have to
describe Schmeling his career spellings
career is interesting because it spanned
the Nazi era I mean he was he was world
champion before Hitler came to power and
so you see how she melling behaves
before Hitler comes to power and then
afterwards and you have to trace that
whole story and the story so I mean the
story starts in the 20s it cullman it
and then the book begins with the fight
and ends with the second fight begins
with this begins with the first fight it
ends with it begins with the second
fight the opening scene at Yankee
Stadium and then ends with you know a
much fuller description of the second
fight and then there's a short epilogue
afterwards describing what happened to
the two men after you know their their
fateful encounter but I I think that I'm
a very perhaps to a fault i mean i'm a
serious researcher I mean I loved
researching this book and at a certain
point it becomes hard to stop it becomes
a kind of addiction in a way because
you're oh you're always looking for the
next wonderful anecdote and you know
that because everybody followed this
everybody wrote about it and so you're
looking at you know after you've gone
through all the newspapers you're
looking through collections of letters
you know you look to see what somebody
if a famous person wrote a letter on jun
23rd 1938 it may well include a
reference to the fight you know most of
the most of the work was based on
newspapers I mean you can imagine there
aren't a lot of people left who remember
who there are a lot of people who
remember the fight they were kids their
parents let them stay up late you know
they have story they have stories about
I mean one guy told me about you know
rushing off to buy a good humor bar for
all of his friends and coming back and
the fight was over you know because the
fight was over in two minutes but they
were kids
and there are a lot of them i think
really anybody over 70 not only
remembers the fight but can remember
where he will you know most people many
people over 70 have very vivid
recollections it's one of those moments
in time like when Kennedy was shot you
know or the Challenger blew up or
whatever it's just one of those moments
that's that's indelibly stamped on
people's minds from that generation
there are only I didn't there are only a
few people left who were at the fight
and you could imagine the people they
weren't a lot of kids at the fight you
know there was one that one guy I
interviewed was the son of the reporter
for The New York Herald Tribune so he
went with his old man to the fight you
know and he had a couple of interesting
stories to tell he told a story about
you know after the fight is over in two
minutes everybody's leaving and then a
man is walking in the other day right
other direction in the stadium in a
tuxedo entails you know with wearing
formal wear which is with some people
you know fancy people wore to these
fights these fights were big social
events and everybody's leaving and he's
rushing in saying what round is it what
round is it you know and of course the
fight was over so there were a few
people like that the only the only
reporter who covered the fight Lester
Rodney of The Daily Worker and I could
go off on a digression about the Daily
Worker because the Communist paper had
its own sports section and why did it
have a sports section to cover Joe Louis
it started the sports section to cover
Joe Louis and Lester Rodney lives in the
bay area he's in his 90s and he was at
the fight he's the last of the reporters
who was there and you know I probably
interviewed maybe five or six people who
were at the fight i wish i could have
interviewed more but there just aren't
that many of them left and and then
every once in a while you know you'd
encounter other people who were touched
by this story who were around back then
I mean for instance there was one guy
after the first Louis Schmeling fight
they were there was rioting all over
America because this is another
digression but Louis was the ten to one
favorite in that fight the first fight
was in 1936 and Louis was the
presumptive heavyweight champion
isn't technically the champion yet Jimmy
Braddock was the champion but everybody
knew that Lewis was going to beat him it
was just a question first of all of
whether he is a black man we get a shot
at him and when it would be that was the
only question and and he'd beaten two
former champions already he'd beaten
Primo Carnera and Max Baer and Schmeling
was just one more sacrificial lamb along
the way but Schmeling was it was a very
scientific boxer and even though he was
9 years older than Lewis he still had a
good boxing mind he wasn't an exciting
boxer but he was a very methodical boxer
and he discovered that when Lewis
through a left jab he dropped his left
afterward and if he wanted to take
enough if you could take enough punches
in the face you could come in and hit
him with a right and that's what he did
and he knocked Lewis out and you know in
an episode you know it's it's a part of
the story that I described at some
length you know you can imagine that
this black saved for this black Savior
this almost messianic religious figure
to lose to lose a fight was an absolute
catastrophe to black America and they
couldn't believe it and there were riots
and they're in a widespread skepticism
that the fight could possibly have been
legitimate you know there had to there
had to have been something crooked
because there was no way that Lewis a
man like Lewis could lose a fair fight
no way and and there was there was
violence in many American cities
afterwards any whites who were
unfortunate enough to find themselves in
black neighborhoods were really in
danger that night because there was
there was just seething anger in black
America that night and in one in one of
the articles from Harlem it described a
man being hit over the head with a tire
iron and having a skull fractured that
night and a man named Wilmer Cooper and
you know you get compulsive when you do
a book like this you want to track down
everything and so I just put Wilmer
Cooper in the phone in the you know in
the computer you know and one of the
computer phone directories and I my
calculation he had to be in his 80s or
his 90s and you know he had
skull fractured that night I mean anyway
I put his name in and a name popped up
Wilmer Cooper somewhere in Harlem East
126 street or something and so with some
trepidation I picked up the phone and I
dialed that number and an old man
answered the phone and I said mr. Cooper
I introduced myself and I said mr.
Cooper this this may sound kind of funny
but do you remember the first Joe Lewis
Max Schmeling fight and he said in a
very fragile voice he said yes he said I
was hurt bad that night it was the same
guy you know it's just you know if one
of the one of those one of those moments
you have when you when you do a book
like this and you try to dig down deep
into the story that's a long filibuster
of an answer but I but I'm happy to take
any other questions or and more
questions from you eventually too yeah
come on up to the microphone or I can
repeat it I can repeat the question to
appeal our generation yet this guy up
here on the wall Yeah Yeah right Holly
let the record show that he's pointing
to ollie yeah what are you talking about
in terms of your research a few months
back lisa is a few months back of neck
smelling passed away right and he was
nearly nearly cinterion right yes right
and I wonder did you read his
autobiography the question is the point
first of all was that Schmeling lived to
the age of 99 died just last februari I
wrote his obituary for the New York
Times yeah I had written at seven years
earlier you know this is the way these
things are done you know you write that
for somebody that important you write
them in advance and it was kind of a
rosetta stone experience for me because
I had written it before I did all the
research for my book so when I had to
dust it off you know to run in the next
day's paper I had to change it a lot
because I learned a lot of different
stuff about him
and one of the things that I learned was
the autobiography you asked me whether
I'd read the autobiography he wrote
three of them yeah he wrote three of
them only one of them was translated
into English I had somebody I don't
speak German but I had somebody a German
speaker read the other two and then I
read the one that was translated into
into English and one of the things that
I learned over that seven-year period
was how unreliable his autobiography was
Schmeling wrote his own history and and
and had a very convenient memory left a
lot of stuff out and was not a reliable
source really for his own story and and
but I was just going to say it during I
read that book as well one of the more
humorous kind of if you want to call it
numerous caused millions of people died
in the Second World War you you
mentioned 20 million Germans would
listen to the fight that I if I'm not
mistaken there were 11 billion Germans
that lost their lives in the second
world right but done one section in
there were spelling is pretty much an
american-based boxer for a long time he
came Baird train here mostly and was up
and was fighting over here and courses
manager was a Jewish American guy right
and there was one episode in that all by
autobiography when he bent over here
training of perhaps getting into some
prize fights and he was about ready to
take the ship back to Germany across the
Atlantic and one of his friends came up
and said some some loan shark or
something like that it really been put
put a lot of pressure on him would he
buy some gold bullion from him we give
him some cash money gold bullion or some
kind of coins or something and smelly
considered him a friend and he did that
when he bought over across the ocean
with him got it back into Germany you
failed to declare it right he got in
some trouble with the authorities yeah
well I you know I I was very interested
I'm very interested obviously in
Schmeling his relationship with with the
Nazi regime and and I write a lot about
that and I think that Schmeling version
of that story is very incomplete and
really sort of dishonest I should say
that that I tried to interview Schmeling
I went to his house I went to his
doorstep Schmeling had a guy who was
designed to deal with people like me you
know sort of visiting reporters and and
and what he would do you go visit him
and he would sort of ply you with the
soft drink and give you a few
autographed pictures and say oh an
interview was quite impossible you know
and he just doesn't know he doesn't give
interviews and in fact he did give
interviews he gave interviews to a few
reporters who could be counted upon to
write nothing challenging and write the
same sort of repeat the same old stories
and sort of the accepted you know the
accepted wisdom that Schmeling had a
jewish manager that he never joined the
Nazi Party you know that he was really
an anti-nazi and just you know to go
through all of that and and I knew this
man was giving me the runaround so I had
nothing to lose so I actually went to Sh
melling's house and some man you know we
I in my translator rang the bell rang
the little butcher the estate was off in
the woods you couldn't see it and some
guy came out and said oh he's not home
and I knew that he was home because he
really didn't leave home very often but
that was as close as I ever got and it
is too bad but I don't think he would
have been any more truthful with me and
it turns out that you know I thought you
know I'm here's a new york guy you know
coming to speak to him perhaps he has a
reason to be skeptical of me and and and
you know his guard is up but it turned
out that for many many years Schmeling
didn't speak even to Germans to join
like German historians would try to
interview him historians of Nazi culture
and his
Dorian's of sports during the hitler
years and that sort of thing would want
to talk to him and he would send them
back postcard saying mr. Schmeling has
answered at all you has has nothing more
to say he's told all the stories already
so I think that I didn't I was skeptical
of his story before I started the book
and I read very very widely in the
newspapers of the day which are a lot
more reliable of course than somebody's
self-serving memoirs for many years
later and and they paint a very
different picture I'll just give you a
couple of snapshots from that the photo
album that I put together in a sense one
is that schmeling comes over as I said
you know he is his tenure as a
top-flight heavyweight boxer spanned the
Vai mar and nazi years he won the
championship in 1930 he lost it in 1932
and that's when he started his comeback
and so he comes to America in 1933 to
fight Max Baer a Californian who at that
point an up-and-coming heavyweight and
you can imagine that after the New York
newspapers at the time in April Hitler
comes to power in January of 1933 and by
April the New York newspapers are filled
with stories about what's going on in
Germany and you can imagine because you
know the the anti-semitic the
anti-jewish decrees started happening
almost immediately and and and and the
the the pogroms and and the the roundups
and everything the death camps didn't
start right away but everything else a
lot of other things started right away
and it was page one news and in all of
the New York papers horrifying
horrifying stories now so there was no
there was no missing all of this I mean
there was no you know everybody in New
York knew about it a hundred thousand
Jews marched in New York a couple weeks
before Schmeling arrived you know to
protest what was going on in Germany
there was no secret to it now in
Schmeling zone world as I as I suggested
here boxing was very important to the
Nazis for two reasons as Hitler you know
as I as I quoted Hitler is saying what
for good boxers made for good soldiers
it was a way to toughen up the German
people you know introduce boxing in the
schools and and and so Hitler Hitler
Hitler thought with boxing would would
make Germany more war ready he also
thought that it would be a great thing
for Nazi Germany to have a heavyweight
champion you know particular somebody
who sort of embodied Nazi ideology sort
of somebody who was you know kind of who
represented Aryan supremacy what bet
what what more prestigious thing could
you have than it had been the
heavyweight champion of the world the
sing this the single greatest honour in
all of sports so boxing was a met with
something that mattered enormously to
Hitler and within a few weeks of Hitler
coming to power all of the Jews were
kicked out of German boxing all right
that meant that there were Jewish title
holders in Germany there was one German
bought one German Jewish boxer who had
who held two titles and he was stripped
of his crowns and he fled for his life
so that meant the Jewish boxers could no
longer box in Germany but it also meant
that German boxers could no longer have
Jewish managers could no longer go to
Jewish doctors could no longer go to
Jewish dentists I mean it just swept
across the board it it would be as if
you know all african-americans were
suddenly kicked out of the NBA I mean it
was an absolute revolution in the sport
you know you know all Hispanics out of
baseball you know it was it was a
revolution in the sport yeah anyway
anyway so what so smelling is asked when
he when Schmeling comes to america the
reporters say to him what's going on in
germany and on Schmeling says everything
is fine in Germany you know everything
is nice and everything is very peaceful
nothing is you know and the and the
problems that the Jews are having are
the problems that the Jews have brought
upon themselves this is what he says and
you know you'd the picture that you just
that you that you describe of Schmeling
is very important at that time he was a
former heavyweight champion of the world
he was the Babe Ruth of Germany he was
the most famous athlete Germany had ever
produced
he was a world-class figure and as you
say he was making his living in New York
City he was making his living not in
Reichsmarks but in dollars because all
of the big fights are in New York so he
might be happy when he was when he was
put upon first by the government this
financial agency he ignored it and then
finally he was threatened with jail time
right declared this well so he called
Hitler on the phone yeah Hitler took
care of them invited you me right and
then he met with Hitler a lot in the
book it states that Hitler got on the
phone music I want you to take care of
this matter immediate right yeah that's
right that's right now you say you never
heard about it again right that's right
yeah yeah I think that yet that's I
think that story is where it is is very
representative and my only point is that
as somebody who made his living in
America and as an asst and as somebody
with really incredible Fame at least
early on and it's very easy you know
it's easy for somebody in my position to
criticize somebody from back then I'm
well aware of that but in the early days
of the regime there was no German who
was free or to tell the truth and Max
Schmeling and he simply didn't do it it
was before the first fight was the the
question was whether the first fight was
before or after the 36 Olympics it was
before the 36 Olympics were in august of
1936 and the first fight was in june of
1936 you have to remember every big
fight every every big fight was outdoors
the note in the era before television
you had to you had to put together the
biggest crowds you possibly could and so
all the big fights are in junior
September in outdoor venues and stadiums
you know which is why there were
ninety-five thousand people in Yankee
Stadium the largest crowd in the history
of Yankee Stadium the Pope didn't get
that many people for the fur for the
Lewises fight against Max Baer and
what's interesting about the timing of
the of the two events is that Jesse
Owens later said
that one of the things that spurred on
him and his african-american teammates
on the Olympic team in 1936 was that
they had to make up for what had
happened to Joe Lewis that Joe Louis's
loss had been you know such a such a
catastrophe for their people that they
were you know they had it they had an
extra added incentive to sort of show
the flag and to do well now some people
some people asked me to describe the the
relative impact of jesse owens and Joe
Lewis when I say there was never another
athlete like Joe Lewis for instance
songs about athletes if you think about
it there are a couple of songs about Joe
DiMaggio I mean can you think of any
songs about about Jesse Owens or or or
Michael Jordan or Willie Mays or Hank
Aaron maybe they they may be i just
don't know of them a musicologist
calculated or assembled 43 joe lewis
songs she put out a woman named Rina
kazursky put out a CD a few years ago
just of Joe Lewis songs and there's a
there's a wonderful story that's told
where in the book by Shirley Povich I
don't know if any of you remember
Shirley Povich Shirley Povich was the
famous sports columnist for 50 or 60
years for the Washington Post also Maury
Povich his father and and Shirley Povich
describes a visit in 1935 when Joe Lewis
and Jesse Owens both come to Washington
for a convention of the Negro Elks and
he says that he describes how around Joe
Lewis Jesse Owens was acting like just a
flunky that even Jesse Owens was in awe
of Joe Lewis and what helps explain that
is that track Jesse always was first of
all a college man he's hard for the
black masses to relate to Jackie
Robinson was the same way whereas John
Lewis's appeal spanned all sectors in
his community that was that was the
first thing but the more important thing
is that boxing was everything boxing was
the second most important
and as I said a heavyweight championship
fight was the biggest event in all of
sports in the heavyweight champion of
the world was the biggest celebrity in
all of sports track and field was a
sideshow you know the Olympics weren't
televised back then they weren't you
know they simply weren't nearly as big a
deal but it is you know in retrospect I
mean obviously that's one of the great
sporting events of the century the 19 36
Olympics and what Jesse Owens and his
teammates did but I think if I you know
if I if I were putting together a list
this would be higher and you know in all
of the lists that were put together
around the millennium of of the most
important events of the 20th century the
most important sporting events I can't
think of one this was on it i mean the
lewis Schmeling fight was on it but I
can't think of any that's that was more
important for all the reasons that I've
described yeah
he came he came in april of 30 32 yeah
the quite that you want to ask it again
it may smelling come to the United
States in April of 1933 to fight Max
Baer mhm now yeah any Jewish community
in the United States giving what had
happened to the stuff to fight him in
June of 1933 yeah now it was the Jewish
community in the United States giving
what had happened in the previous four
or five months since Hitler came into
power did they look in on Max Baer being
a Jew did did that have any influence in
regards to them wanting so fervently to
Joe Lewis to beat max schmeling when
they fought again and well it's it's an
intra it's an interesting thing the
consensus is that max beer was not
Jewish okay max baer represented himself
as Jewish and even wore a Star of David
on his trunks but Max Baer was not
Jewish that's the that's the first
that's the first point to be made I mean
but why did he want to be Jewish why did
he want to represent himself as Jewish
very interesting I mean at a time when
Jews were fleeing Germany for their
lives Gentile boxers were trying to be
Jewish in New York why was that it's
because there were so many Jewish fans
and and you know it was every fight
promoters dream to find a Jewish
heavyweight you know Jewish heavyweight
champion and bear had some you know
Jewish blood in him from way back and so
he tried to he tried to represent
himself as Jewish and you can imagine
that you know he made statements like
you know every every time I land a
bloated on Schmeling it's a blow on it's
a punch against Adolf Hitler you know he
played this to the hilt bear was from
California and one of the new york
sports writers said you know the closer
to New York he that he gets the more
Jewish he becomes you know if you were
if he kept going over the Atlantic he'd
be five hundred percent Jewish you know
and I mean bears father was a pork
farmer he raised pigs you know it didn't
you know it didn't exactly help his you
know make his case more credible but the
fight was nonetheless framed as a fight
between a jew and a 10 and a German you
know the promoters were very happy to
carry on with this idea to
but I don't think that there was much of
a connection between those fights the
Jews didn't need that fight to support
Joe Lewis later on you know they just
they just they saw they saw they they
saw smelling with a swastika on his
forehead Schmeling as I said never join
the not-see party and this is one of the
points that's always raised in his
defense and I you know my own feeling is
he had no particular inclination to join
the not-see party he wasn't a terribly
political guy I have to say that in his
favor but it would have been suicidal
for him to join the not-see party I mean
if you're gonna box in New York why
would you announce that you're a Nazi
you know there's no way you wouldn't
you'd be boycotted out of business you
know now the same thing is true
schmeling gets a lot of credit for
having had a Jewish manager you know I
was on kgo yesterday and and and
somebody called up and said I was being
too hard on schmeling he had a Jewish
manager after all and Schmeling you know
always talked about this and his
autobiography now how could I have been
a Nazi sympathizer I had a Jewish
manager and for the you know for the
same reason that he never that he would
never the Nazis didn't watch melling to
become a member of the party and the
Nazis wanted Schmeling to have a Jewish
manager they were very happy the Nazis
were not stupid they were very pragmatic
they knew that in order for this man to
do business in New York City he needed
the Jew to run interference for him a
Jew was his house his Good Housekeeping
Seal of Approval okay a Jew afforded him
cut that precisely the protection that
Schmeling suggested you know how could I
how could I be intolerant I have a
Jewish manager and the Jewish manager
isn't as a wonderful character Joe
Jacobs one of my favorite characters in
the book one of these old-fashioned
Damon Runyon kinds of guys the man who
originated the term we was robbed and
he's in Bartlett's you know we was
robbed he also famously said I should
have stood in bed you know he's got to
entry I don't have any entries in
Bartlett's but this man does and I've
been writing for 25 years but you know
everything he said was probably was a
wonder
a colorful character but if you read the
articles at the time you realize that
that that Schmeling treated him
abysmally he kept cutting his
commissions I mean SH melons treatment
of Joe Jacobs was a scandal at the time
but you know if you live long enough and
you write n you get to write your own
history these things are for these
things are these things are forgotten
and so it's another respect in which
I've tried to set the record straight
you know there's a wonderful story about
Joe Jacobs and a picture in the book
also where he went back to Germany he
also became a very controversial figure
because he kept coming back from Germany
and saying everything is fine you know I
went to synagogue over there you know
the I saw Jews and all the cafe's Jewish
businesses are still going everything is
fine and and you know he became a very
controversial figure in the Jewish
community for that reason anyway they're
11 of Schmeling famous fights I mean
famous to my mind in fact completely
free I'm so twisted by having lived in
this world for so long I've I have to I
have to watch myself it's famous in my
mind it's completely forgotten by
everybody else there was a fight in 1935
between Schmeling I'm still on his
comeback trying to get us another
another shot at the title against an
American boxer named Steve heinous a
rematch smelling had lost to him the
first time in Philadelphia and they have
a rematch in Germany in 1935 in Hamburg
and the Nazis set out the Nazis were so
hungry for legitimacy in world opinion
they wanted to show that they wanted to
break the American hegemony on boxing
they wanted to show that we Nazi Germany
can put on as good a fight as any
Americans can you know and we're going
to not only that we're going to build a
place that's even bigger than Madison
Square Garden it was very important for
them to be bigger and better so and
we're going to do it in a few months
we're going to work that we're going to
show that you know the new spirit in
Nazi Germany is capable of building a
gigantic arena bigger than Madison
Square Garden and staging a great fight
you know and maybe we'll soon have a
heavyweight championship fight over you
know when the Olympics are over we're
going to need more athletic spectacles
to show you know the resurgence of Nazi
Germany and so they have this fight in
hamburg in in march of 1935 and it
becomes i have a long description of it
in the book because it's kind of
mesmerizing to read about it to read the
accounts of it at the time you know
people swastika uniformed men everywhere
you know and this very obedient pliable
crowd you know and everybody's sitting
very up straight and very regimented and
and you know there are many there are
fascinating accounts particularly from
British reporters writing about the
spirit in that Hall you know somebody
said you know the Germany of two you
know the Germans of today are just oh
they're awaiting orders they're willing
to take any orders that are given to
them I mean they could they could see
the spirit of Nazi Germany in that Hall
that night and after after Schmeling
wins knocks him out in a brutal brutal
fight why was the fight brutal because
the referee had been told this fight has
to be legit there can't be any questions
we don't want anything to sully the
reputation of Nazi Germany no ambiguity
don't call this fight even after it's
clear the guy is losing don't call it we
want a clean knockout okay and so the
you know smelling practically kills the
guy that night and there's this frenzy
in the hall after he wins and you know
you can hear the sound of Vagner in the
distance coming over you know coming
over the public address system and then
25,000 Germans get up and start singing
Deutschland uber alles as Schmeling goes
into the ring and everybody starts
saluting you know and and and the
british reporter writes you know i wore
a uniform in world war one I hope never
to have to put another uniform on but
you know from what I saw here tonight
he's writing for his British audience I
may have to put this uniform back on and
so may you they're preparing for the
next war he saw that in the Boxing Hall
that night and it's justin to me is sort
of unfair an unforgettable description
anyway they all go in the ring
and and even though Joe Jacobs can't
represent schmeling he drags them he
spelling drags Jacobs up into the ring
to sort of join the celebration and when
everybody else starts saluting Joe
Jacobs the American Jew gives the salute
okay and the only problem is he has a
garnish yet a cigar in his hand when he
did you know but so if it you know you
can imagine that Nazi Germany was
scandalized by it but you could but you
know and there you know and there was
comment in the press afterwards but the
you know the New York Jewish community
wasn't crazy about it either you know
and Joe Jacobs as you know is attacked
viciously in the Yiddish press for being
you know for being a traitor to his
people and that that was when you know
Jacobs said was I supposed to do you
know when you see when when they start
playing the star-spangled banner you
know you stand up and I was in their
country and the way he put it was when
in Rome eat pasta fazool you know he was
over there he was following the local
custom you had a question back there I'm
not familiar so forgive me but um what
did you have the opportunity to talk to
any of the descendents or Joe Louis's
family and if so what was their response
to the book or did he have anyone that
has had any feedback um well I talked to
Joe Louis's son he's not a writer he has
written a book yeah he's written a book
but he's sort of a sports entrepreneur
and he's a very nice guy but he was born
after you know born long after the story
that I tell and I you know I didn't I I
felt I think I'd heard what he had to
say already because he'd been
interviewed a lot before and so I didn't
I didn't concentrate on that in my
research Joe Louis has a daughter and I
never I never spoke to her I've never
seen her quoted anywhere he also had
various siblings but I think all of them
were gone by the time I started the book
I did speak once to one of his nieces
who was a lovely woman a schoolteacher
who lived I think she
schoolteacher who lived in Detroit and
she had some interesting stories to tell
I mean one story that she told which
interested me was as i mentioned lewis's
managers Lewis had black managers Julian
black and John roxburgh one from Chicago
and one from Detroit and part of part of
their attempt to make sure that Louis
Lewis's image was squeaky clean was that
you know they are they always had
pictures of him reading the Bible and
and and and and being a devoted son
there are always pictures of his mother
everywhere you know and his mother gave
long interviews and you know sort of
writing about her faith in her son and
her faith in American fairness and you
know they were going to she had always
treated white people right and so white
people were going to treat her right and
treat her son right and there are these
very homey stories from her kind of make
you cringe but one of one of them one of
the stock stories about Lewis was that
you know he didn't go out and waste his
money the way that Jack Johnson did on
fancy things he bought his mother a home
that was how he spent his money you know
I mean you had a double whammy there you
know not only was he spending his money
on something wise rather than something
extravagant and foolish but it was for
his mother you know and he spent sixty
five hundred dollars to buy her a very
nice respectable not a fancy house we
don't want no fancy house you know just
a nice respectable home and and I always
why was curious about this house just
because it got such enormous publicity
at the time and and Louis's niece whom I
met in Detroit told me that that house
like the neighborhood you know the black
bottom / Paradise Valley neighborhood
where that Lewis came from in Detroit
was pretty much wiped out when they put
the interstate highway through and and
the government had you know offered them
a pittance and that house was torn down
and you know it's just it's just one
more I didn't know that story you know
it was just one more little sort of
footnote of indignity you know that I
that that she told me about I mean
that's but I'm trying to think of
whether or not there were any other
Schmeling had no relatives I mean he he
was married to an actress named Annie
Andhra but they had no children on
Aundre there's a picture of audio injure
listening to the first fight with Joseph
and Magda gurbles at their home you know
that's where she listened to the fight
that night but they had no kids so there
were no descendants there to speak with
and I think apart from Louis's son and
his niece there were really no other
there were no other family members to
speak to speak with and there were no
there were no sort of boxing officials I
mean this is why the research took the
form that it did it became mostly
newspapers and when I when I say
newspapers I mean newspapers I mean I
are there were nine New York newspaper
is then and because as I say they all
covered boxing very intensely and the
boxing columnist were wonderful and you
know i mean i've been criticized for
having too many quotes in the book you
know I maybe I should plead guilty it's
just that there are so many wonderful
quotes you know so many great people to
quote you know so many vivid wonderful
things you know the people wrote about
all of this back then so the New York
newspapers and then there were the black
papers you know every city had it you
know every city had every major American
city had a black weekly newspaper
largely forgotten now and and just
treasure troves of insight and
information and color you know just
wonderfully rich material in there you
know the Chicago Defender the Pittsburgh
courier the Norfolk journal and guide
the afro-american of washington /
baltimore you know and i and i read some
much more obscure ones you know in every
and every once in a while you know you'd
find you'd find some wonderfully obscure
but telling detail i remember i read the
otherwise pretty undistinguished black
newspaper from houston okay and there
wasn't much information in there i think
it was either houston or dallas maybe
dallas and there was an account in there
of of the fight films at the films of
the 1936
fight the film's obviously we're a big
business you know most people couldn't
go to the fights but everybody went to
the film's afterwards and that you know
there was a big box office for them but
what happened in the south you know well
in some southern cities films between
the there was a there was officially it
was against the law against federal law
to traffic interstate and fight films it
was a legacy of Jack Johnson fight films
cause riots and so they banned them but
the bait but the ban was usually
overlooked when two whites were fighting
one another it was no big deal but when
a black was fighting a white these bands
were applied very selectively so that
for instance in Richmond Virginia the
films of the Lewis Schmeling the films
of the Lewis bear fight were banned in
Richmond Virginia why a black man beat a
white man ok but the films of the
smelling when Schmeling knocked out
Louis those films were allowed in
Richmond because they're a white man was
beating a black man ok this is the kind
of little insight into the racial
culture and fabric of the country back
then anyway in this in this black paper
in in Houston or Dallas they had an
account of how this one theater in
Dallas was going to show the Lewis
smelling films for blacks ok midnight
showings it would show for whites every
other tell you know every other hour it
would be for whites but three nights in
a row there would be showing for
african-americans at midnight and the
film the theater held 1300 people and
they expected to sell out all three
nights you know it was just a little
tiny item in the paper you know it's
just one of those little gifts that you
that you get you know when you start you
know you start reading you know you
start reading like that so i read i read
the black papers i read the papers in
Chicago because Chicago was where Lewis
lived Detroit because that's where he
grew up Philadelphia Washington la San
Francisco and then to say nothing of the
German papers I mean I had I had help
with this because i don't i don't speak
it but i had people canvassing all the
leading German papers the French papers
the English papers that's
where I found this description of the
heinous fight you know in one of the
English papers South African papers
South American papers Yiddish papers I
even tried Russian papers because
there's one reference to pravda which
father is vestian followed you know
followed the fight and had an item about
how Hitler's hero had been knocked out
close friends with a with a French boxer
Carpentier well yeah he showed up the
question is whether he was friendly with
a French boxer yeah it's another
forgotten thing but he was friendly with
carp carp on ta and simply by showing up
with him during the war car ponte a
simply by having been seen with
Schmeling during the war and Schmeling
wartime activities are interesting part
of his story car ponte a was seen with
Schmeling had a cup of coffee with him
or was photographed with him in a
restaurant in Paris during the German
occupation and was accused of
collaboration in part because he had
simply been seen with Schmeling yeah
what was Joe Louis's mindset going into
the second fight how large in his mind
was this was this a world of an or for
him was it made mainly just a rematch I
think that that it's an interesting it's
an interesting question Lewis never wore
his emotions on his sleeves he was a
very taciturn guy he didn't you never
would never have let on that he knew
that the weight of the world was on his
shoulders or that the weight of his own
people was on his shoulders so his
demeanor was he didn't say very much he
never said very much it was you know
even the black writers I mean you know
there are a lot of racial stereotypes of
Lewis and the white press but even the
black writers had problems with him you
didn't say anything you know somebody
just no described how a black writer
describes sitting in a room with Lewis
Lewis was in a room with a statue and he
said the statue made lino made Lewis
seem loquacious or something you know
lewiston's you know Lewis didn't say
anything
I think that so he didn't but but it was
very clear Lewis didn't like Schmeling
you know there's this image of them as
great buddies that again I think there's
a lot of mythology and sort of wishful
thinking in that after the war that they
were great friends and the story is told
it's a very popular story that Schmeling
paid for Lois's funeral Joe Louis's
lawyer I should mention that I spoke to
him he's in 93 years old Truman Gibson
lovely man just came out with a book of
his own memoirs Joe Louis's lawyer says
that story's not true that that
Schmeling paid for Lois's funeral and I
you know I was skeptical of it but I'm
more skeptical of it now but it was very
it was very clear that that night Lewis
was Lewis saw it mostly I think as a
grudge match I think that but it was a
grudge match partly because he was
offended by some of shillings comments
Schmeling was very careful about what he
said he very rarely every once in a
while he would say something about how
things were great in Nazi Germany but he
was smart enough not to say that very
often you know and generally when the
topic of politics came up he would
change the subject you know he would
just talk about anything else he
wouldn't he wouldn't talk about that but
there were a couple of instances where
Schmeling talked about race you know and
what he suggested was there was one one
quote where he said the black domination
of boxing has to end you know and I'm
doing my share in the heavyweight
division you know its up to other boxers
too to do that in other divisions he was
quoted as saying that a quote to a
Chicago paper that wasn't picked up
anywhere I mean no other white paper
picked it up it was in the Black Press
is to show you about the sort of racial
sensitivity of the time and you can
imagine if somebody said something like
that now but I had a hell of a time
finding that quote I knew that it
existed it was in a Chicago paper that a
friend of mine found for me so there
were occasional quotes like that and
Schmeling had also said in so many words
that a black man will never forget the
beating that I gave him okay not this
black man
man that black men reacted to beatings
differently than whites did they were
spooked you know they were they were
they there was something different about
their psychological reaction to a
beating they didn't get over it the same
way that we get we do and he was quoted
as saying something like that he also
had given an interview to Paul gallico
in The Saturday Evening Post one of the
great sports writers of the era in which
in which he said that Lewis had fouled
him intentionally in the first fight
then Lewis knew he was going to lose the
first fight and the only way that he
could win was too with lote with low
blows that he threw deliberately and the
first fight Lewis was knocked down in
the fourth round and he went and
Schmeling had hit him late after the
bell in the fifth round and he was
groggy the rest of the way and he didn't
know what he was doing and it was clear
that he hadn't thrown the punches
deliberately and for someone to question
his sportsmanship as I say this was a
man who was always on his best behavior
in public that was part of his image I
mean he had to maintain his image he had
to be you can imagine how the
powers-that-be would have come down on a
black boxer who fought dirty and so he
had to be cleaner than anybody else and
for somebody to question his ethics like
that particularly after he Schmeling
himself had thrown a late punch
deliberately you know after the fifth
after the bell in the fifth round it
rankled Lewis and so Louis the the the
story is that Lewis was very angry that
night and of course he came out you know
in two minutes and four seconds really
that you know the most electrifying two
minutes and four seconds in the history
of boxing probably and just you know
creamed them had him on the ropes very
very quickly punched him in the side as
Schmeling turn broke two of his
vertebrae you know she Melling ended up
in the hospital for ten days you know I
mean the first time you mentioned before
when Schmeling went back to Germany
after that first fight he was given a
berth on the Hindenburg the Hindenburg
was still around you know and fax
Welling was supposed to have been on the
Hindenburg the time it blew up but
because of Joe Jacobs among other people
he'd come over earlier and missed that
fly
and hadn't blown up but the first time
he'd come back on the he'd gone back on
the Hindenburg and you know met you know
you can imagine he would what a huge
already you know a hero of unimaginable
dimensions in Germany and then to land
from the Hindenburg you know and sort of
descend from on high and you know they
meet with adoring crowds in Frankfurt
and Berlin meets with Hitler and
Goebbels the next day and then after the
second fight he goes back on a stretcher
you know to a very too much quieter
reception it's a very it's a very
dramatic contrast said it thank you
David Margaux lake is a contributing
editor at Vanity Fair